hey youtubers is Charlie so if you
haven't seen they just released a world
of ice and fire you can buy it on Amazon
there's even a kindle edition so what it
is is like in ancient history of
Westeros written by George our Martin
this video is just gonna be a cursory
breakdown of what the chapters are and
some of the stuff that you can find in
the book just a quick reminder I know
you guys will like this I'm giving away
copies of the book all you have to do to
enter the giveaway is be a subscriber
and leave a comment I'll try and give
one away for each bonus video that I do
just because most of you probably
haven't had time to read it yet I'm not
gonna get into spoilers are really
specific details from the book I'm just
gonna pick out a few bits for people
that are really big fans of the books
this will tide you over until season
five gets here I mean it is literally
like a thousand pages long I haven't got
my hardback copy yet I'm actually been
reading my kindle copy so right off the
bat it's written in third person just
like dance the Dragons like George are
Martin is writing it as a maester
recording history
not so much recording history as
recalling history are trying to piece
through history the protagonists name is
maester Yandel he Tommen's name is
specifically mentioned in the preface so
you can think of masteryand ol is living
in present-day like he's alive right now
where we are in the books the history is
all ancient history like very ancient
history long night rise of ancient
Valyria the first men the dawn age all
the things that we always wanted to talk
about but that the Canon hadn't really
gotten into yet technically old man's
stories are Canon because they're
written by george RR martin but you get
the idea i really did like the maestra
voice the george RR martin spoke with
when he was writing dance of the dragons
versus the first-person POV style that
he uses in the main novels just think of
him is like an analog of Samwell like
imagine what Samwell sounds like when
he's speaking to himself in his own head
they did release an egg on chapter 4
Aegon the first that explained his
history and his conquering of the Seven
Kingdoms so if you read that then you
kind of know how the rest of the book
reads at least the style that it reads
so we have one new character - the next
big thing that he revealed about the
book George our Martin is that he left a
lot of stuff out what does that mean
well it means he probably just left out
things that are critical to
understanding what's going on and winds
of winter in the future books so in
terms of seeing spoilers in the book for
future things in the novel's do not
worry George are Martin has you totally
covered he's not gonna spoil his
audience that also brings up the issue
of unreliable narration from some of the
characters
meister yonder the person who's
narrating the book acknowledges the
difference between recorded history in
actual history like during the dawn age
for instance he talks a lot about the
Giants and the fact that nobody recorded
any of their history for them like they
don't have their own recorded history
and at the time no one was recording
history so most of what they know is all
conjecture I just think it's George R
Martin winking at the audience saying
this might be true it might not be true
number three big big battles big big
Game of Thrones
one of the things that Martin is really
good at is getting into the real politic
of history like if your students sitting
in a history class reading a textbook a
little bit of the book reads like that
so you learn very specific names very
specific events he does cover things
through Duncan egg the Bloodraven a lot
of the things that we found in the other
books in the expanded materials that
just haven't really been talked about a
lot the events of the book take us up to
where we are on the show right now so it
does deal a little bit with Robert's
rebellion not the spoilery parts though
no you do not find out who Jon Snow's
mother is like Martin isn't gonna spoil
that number for the gods and magic some
of it's conjecture some of its no in
fact the book does dispel a couple of
myths he dresses the issue of people
thinking of Heaven and Hell like the God
in the devil it'll be really fun to
revisit everything when season five
starts especially when he releases wins
a win or two and no he did not reveal
when that's happening aunt number five
all about dragons the book really gets
into the rise and fall of dragons you
can almost say it's like the rise in the
fall of the Targaryen family although
technically the Targaryens weren't a big
household in the blue tier in Freehold
although now that Daenerys is the mother
of the Dragons she's largely brought
them back into the world so it is
interesting to think that the fate of
dragons is tied to the fate of the
Targaryen family number six the world is
getting bigger so for anyone who is like
a big fan of the book of maps that they
released a long time ago he explains the
rise of all the kingdoms like all the
big cities all the big places like the
Free Cities for instance he explains how
they became the Free Cities there's a
whole chapter on the creation and rise
of Braavos as well as a number of other
cities number seven complete family
trees so he has complete family trees
for the Targaryen the Starks and the
Lannisters pretty much the three most
popular houses in the show if you've
seen there's some really awesome
pictures that really get into it it gets
really really
complicated the books really only
address a fraction of these family trees
but now world of Ice and Fire just puts
it all in front of your face number
eight the reign of kings
starting with Aegon the cocker he has a
timeline of every King to sit on the
Iron Throne to Tommen number nine
beautiful illustrations so here's just a
few of the many many just mind-blowing
illustrations that are in the book
like I said this is a really long book
so there's a ton of time to read it the
videos that I'm going to be doing for it
won't necessarily be super spoilery but
I will get into more specific things
just based on stuff that you guys really
want to talk about but I'll probably do
is just break into little bits and just
start chronologically work my way
through if you have any specific things
that you'd really like to talk about out
of the book just let me know I'll be
sure to add it to my list so in case you
haven't seen it they're making a whole
bunch of changes in season 5 I do a
breakdown right here you can learn all
about them and you can click here to
learn all about the flashbacks that
we're gonna be getting that's right
they're gonna be doing a few flashbacks
thank you so much for watching so it's
all high five and I'll see you guys
tonight